j'ai vu que ça ça crée une espèce de
controverse exactement mauvaise humeur
mais oui tu as raison moi je n'ai écarté
personne j'ai simplement souhaité parler
avec peu de personnes parce que je me
sens plus à l'aise pour parler avec peu
de personnes et aussi voilà quand tu
m'as demandé de choisir j'ai choisi des
personnes dont j'étais certain de la
bienveillance et puis et puis surtout
je pense qu'on a le droit d'avoir envie
de parler avec une personne et peut-être
moins avec une autre c'est voilà c'est
un droit humain et surtout je pense que
les choses dont on va parler aujourd'hui
ça mérite
qu'on débatte et moi je me sens toujours
plus à l'aise avec une personne qui est
là pour débattre que pour m'abattre
voilà c'est pas mal ça
c'est pas mal non c'est pas mal c'est
une belle formule alors donc là je pense
qu'on va débattre et si c'est très
intéressant moi je demande pas sûr qu'on
soit d'accord avec moi mais je pense que
quand on quand on débat il faut créer
les conditions de l'amitié c'est à dire
il faut accorder à l'autre le crédit ses
arguments et à partir du moment on fait
ça et ben on va penser ensemble en
confrontant nos idées et la lumière va
jaillir de ces deux silex qu'on va
frotter qui vont choisir le feu voilà
alors
Francis on va parler de cette histoire
parce que après on verra voilà la
dernière fois que tu étais venu mais là
j'aimerais qu'on parle de ton actu
puisque
il y en a un qui a voulu faire un retour
médiatique sur le thème du pardon c'est
Dieudonné
pareil que c'est toi d'ailleurs qui
avait été le un peu le prometteur entre
ce journal qui avait publié l'interview
de Dieudonné et Dieudonné c'est Israël
magazine André Darmon vous avez dit que
c'était toi qui avait fait un peu le
Gobi twin ben oui pourquoi tu
connaissais bien Israël magazine bah oui
d'accord et donc tu t'es dit tu connais
bien Israël je connais bien André
darmonie
ne me connaissent alors pour toi ce que
Dieudonné est sincère dans son pardon
parce que on va parler après de ton
projet avec lui oui écoute franchement
moi je n'ai aucun doute là-dessus
d'ailleurs si tu veux être assuré de sa
sincérité il faut que tu écoutes la
réponse qu'il a faite à Soral c'est
marrant c'est tous ces gens qui ont
besoin de la haine il y a des gens qui
ont besoin de la haine ils étaient très
proches avec Alain Soral et est-ce qu'il
lui a fait comme réponse ce qu'il m'a
dit il faut que tu écoutes mais c'est
pas tu peux pas me le dire c'est long
mais si tu veux en gros en gros Alain
Soral lui reproche de demander pardon à
la communauté exactement d'ailleurs
comme le le CRIF lui reproche aussi et
de demander pardon la communauté et ça
c'est un des miracles de finalement de
la du repentir de Dieudonné c'est que
pour la première fois quand même Soral
et le Christ sont mains dans la main ils
sont sur la même ligne
poser des questions il y a eu tellement
de choses
c'est-à-dire le gars il monte un une un
mouvement qui s'appelle Égalité et
Réconciliation et quand quelqu'un veut
se réconcilier ben il l'insulte il
injurie etc donc moi je trouve que il y
a des gens qui ont besoin dans la
société de la haine
se pose des questions c'est normal un
moment non c'est vrai voilà moi
j'aimerais bien que le Christ se pose
des questions mais là il y répond c'est
à dire que le cri fait un procès
d'intention à Dieudonné non mais après
après les gens ne sont pas obligés de
pardonner non il y a des gens voilà
c'est après tu fais on peut faire des
trucs très graves demain je vais faire
un truc très grave je vais dire bah
excusez-moi le lendemain je vais pas je
veux dire pardon les gens sont pas
obligés de le pardonner après qui ont
envie de le pardonner il y en a qui sont
tout le monde n'est pas obligé de
personne n'est obligé de pardonner mais
on peut pas empêcher quelqu'un de
demander pardon
il s'ag empêcher quelqu'un de demander
pardon et personne ne peut nous obliger
à calmer personne et d'ailleurs c'est
pas le souhait de d'ailleurs il l'a dit
dans sa première il a dit je ne cherche
aucune excuse car nul n'en a lorsqu'il
est conscient qu'il a offensé et qu'il a
fait du tort à autrui alors c'est pas
des excuses Cyril quand tu demandes
pardon tu te cherches pas d'excuses
c'est-à-dire que tu Soulages ta
conscience tu Soulages ta conscience
parce que tu penses que tu as nuit à
autrui donc moi je dis simplement que là
aujourd'hui manifestement au moment où
Dieudonné fait un acte de repentir il y
a des gens qui lui font un procès
d'intention parce que très probablement
ils n'ont pas intérêt à ce que Dieudonné
perd de cette image
erronée d'antisémite sur ça voilà je me
dis les gens c'est normal que ils ont
été beaucoup de gens étaient extrêmement
échaudés extrêmement choqués par toutes
ces déclarations à un moment voilà ils
peuvent aussi avoir un doute alors
pourquoi se revirement le Dieudonné
français tu sais alors c'est très
marrant la manière dont ça s'est passé
parce que moi j'étais un des plus
virulents des tracteurs de Dieudonné
j'ai dit des choses mais terribles sur
lui et d'ailleurs j'en ai même dit qui
était contraire à mes valeurs et
moi-même je me suis choqué d'avoir dit
ça et tu sais moi je me convoque tous
les jours à mon propre tribunal et quand
j'ai fait quelque chose de pas bien ben
je me condamne et la première chose que
je fais je vais voir la personne à qui
j'ai tort et je lui demande pardon et
moi vis-à-vis de lui même si j'étais
absolument totalement hostile assez
assez test ce que je pensais être ces
thèse j'estimais que j'avais j'avais
outrepassé mon droit humain et que je
l'avais je l'avais agressé que j'avais
dit des choses que je regrettais d'avoir
dit parce que c'était pas conforme à mes
valeurs j'ai dit qu'il un type comme lui
ne devrait même pas avoir le droit de
parler alors je suis allé le voir et je
lui ai dit alors que tu étais
extrêmement colère contre lui c'est toi
qui a demandé
c'est moi qui ai demandé à mon ami Chloé
Framery dont je savais qu'elle était son
ami il doit me donner son numéro de
téléphone et je l'ai appelé et là je lui
ai dit écoute voilà moi j'exécre tout ce
que tu es tout ce que tu dis tout ce que
tu fais mais je je transmettre mal
comporté envers toi avoir dit des choses
que je regrette et comme je pense qu'un
être humain normal doit le faire je te
demande pardon d'avoir fait ça et là à
ce moment là c'est toi qui va demander
pardon oui je vais demander pardon parce
que je pense que j'étais allé trop loin
dans ce que j'avais dit mais comme ça
pardon était très loin c'est pas une
raison parce que quelqu'un fait quelque
chose de mal pour faire la même chose
donc moi c'est le droit de réagir avec
aussi j'ai le droit de réagir jusqu'à
une certaine mesure j'ai dit des choses
moi le combattant de la liberté
d'expression j'ai dit qu'il n'avait pas
le droit de s'exprimer je regrette
d'avoir dit ça il y a des choses sur
lesquelles un moment
je je te rejoins il a été beaucoup trop
loin ah oui mais d'ailleurs si il
s'excuse aujourd'hui s'il demande pardon
c'est parce que lui-même juge qu'il est
allé trop loin sinon il demanderait pas
pardon et donc ça il est beaucoup plus
loin que toi dans tes paroles envers lui
je trouve bah c'est pas tu sais c'est
pas les Jeux olympiques de du maldire
c'est pas les Jeux olympiques de de
l'offense donc alors qu'est-ce qui t'a
dit quoi donc au moment où je lui
demande pardon il me dit écoute Francis
on est le jour de Pâques aujourd'hui
est-ce que tu je pense vraiment qu'un
chrétien comme moi peut refuser ton
pardon et là je comprends qu'il est
chrétien parce que je pensais pas qu'il
était chrétien je pensais que c'était un
fondamentaliste qui se baladait avec une
ceinture d'explosif dans les banlieues
pour pour appeler à la destruction de
l'État d'Israël et en fait c'est un
chrétien militant comme moi un chrétien
pratiquant et il me dit tu sais quand tu
as dit ces choses-là ça m'a blessé
profondément pas simplement moi mais ça
m'a blessé pour toi parce que je pense
que tu t'es abaissé à dire ces choses et
il avait raison il m'en a remis une
deuxième c'est pour ça que je lui
demandais pardon et là au moment où je
vais partir il me dit est-ce que je peux
te demander quelque chose tu dis oui
est-ce que moi aussi je peux te demander
pardon parce que je sais que je t'ai
fait du tort il m'a fait du tort à
plusieurs moments dans des dispositifs
que j'avais mis en place j'étais très en
colère contre lui il le savait
et je lui dis bah écoute oui j'accepte
ton pardon mais est-ce que tu pourrais
aller plus loin je lui dis est-ce que
par exemple tu pourrais demander pardon
à tous les gens qui se sentent offensés
parce que tu as fait et dit notamment
dans la communauté juive il me dit
Francis c'est mon vœu le plus cher mais
je n'arrive pas à trouver quelqu'un qui
accepte de recevoir mon pardon et quand
il m'a dit ça tout d'un coup moi j'ai je
me suis dit que c'était très important
qu'il puisse le faire et donc j'en ai
fait une affaire personnelle et je lui
ai dit tu ne connais pas cette
communauté moi je la connais bien je
l'aime profondément et il y a dans cette
communauté des gens qui bien sûr ne sont
pas d'accord pour recevoir ton pardon
mais il y en a beaucoup que tu as
offensé qui sont très touchés par ton
par ton message de ta demande de pardon
parce qu'en plus tu leur annuis à deux
de deux manières tu leur ennuies parce
que tu les as offensés mais surtout tu
leur asnuies parce que tu les as privé
de leur comique préféré parce que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui dans la communauté
juive qui adoraient Dieudonné et puis et
puis qui quand a commencé à dire ces
choses là ont été aussi privés de leur
comique préféré c'est pas le c'est pas
le premier truc auquel ils ont pensé ils
ont déjà été très choqués bien
évidemment mais si je peux me permettre
je connais moi j'ai énormément d'amis
juifs et tu le sais pourquoi il est
sincère mais ça fait longtemps ça fait
pas l'ombre d'un doute et sinon moi je
me mets jamais fait un spectacle avec
lui aussi parce que tu vas faire jamais
jamais 6 mois si moi je pensais à un
moment qui avait une once de des gens
qui disent que vous faites un coup
médiatique mais les gens disent ce
qu'ils veulent de moi je te dis ce que
je sens ce que je sais qui a gagné ça
c'est sûr ça c'est sûr en tout cas ce
qui me concerne c'est sûr et lui aussi
d'ailleurs parce que lui il a pas besoin
de de tout ça pour gagner sa vie pour
remplir les selles lui lui il a un truc
il a il a mis en place un système
économique parallèle qu'est-ce qui a
fait juste Francis il est qui voilà
vrillé comme ça qui s'est dit
aujourd'hui j'ai envie qu'on me demande
pardon j'ai envie de de demander pardon
de demander pardon mais ça fait ça fait
longtemps qu'il a cette envie mais qu'il
n'y arrive pas c'est à dire qu'il pas
parce qu'il connaît pas bien cette
communauté je dis faut que je te
présente des gens ils en est arrivé là à
dire à faire des trucs comme ça écoute
ça c'est ça c'est ce qui t'en a parlé ou
bien sûr bien sûr mais ça si tu veux je
me demande si c'est pas hors sujet parce
que lui effectivement il a il a des
circonstances atténuantes parce qu'il a
été embarqué il le dit lui-même il a eu
des mauvais démons pour lui hein
circonstances atténuante on peut pas
accepter non mais le phrase lui-même
lui-même a dit qu'il n'en cherchait pas
lui-même a dit il n'en cherchait pas tu
m'as posé une question c'est à dire
comment est-ce qu'un moment donné alors
qu'il n'est pas antisémite il s'est
trouvé en bringué dans dans toutes ces
choses affreuses qu'il a dit tu es fait
bon lui on en a parlé mais je pense que
c'est pas le sujet lui si un jour tu
fais une émission là-dessus il te
l'expliquera moi il me l'a expliqué mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que le c'est
pas le sujet le comment il en est arrivé
à faire le mal le sujet c'est j'ai fait
le mal et je demande pardon et quand on
refuse l'idée qu'il puisse demander
pardon c'est qu'on est en train de faire
le pro pardon c'est de passion procès à
lui qu'on fait et je suis heureux que
Jean-Marie soit là parce que Jean-Marie
lui il sait ce que c'est que le pardon
et le je pense que le pardon c'est
quelque chose qui élève notre âme
pardonner ça élève notre âme et demander
pardon ça élève notre âme je vais
raconter une anecdote il faut que tu
dises le pardon tu te rappelles à
l'époque tu étais venu à comédie il y a
très longtemps sur la chaîne Comédie oui
tu avais fait remplir un questionnaire
et on t'avait demandé qu'est-ce que tu
dirais quel serait le dernier mot que tu
dirais avant de mourir et ta limite
pardon tu sais que je me rappelle très
bien donc c'est beau que tu te
souviennes de ça ça me fait plaisir tu
vois je me rappelle et on en avait
reparlé avec les équipes et et c'est
vous qu'aujourd'hui tu reparles de ça
c'est vraiment le pardon pourquoi c'est
ça c'est franchement le pardon c'est une
lumière qui nous qui nous délivre du du
mal qui nous ronge et et quand tu
arrives à pardonner tu sais je vais te
raconter une histoire et c'est pour ça
aussi que j'aime tant le peuple juif
c'est que il a quand même souffert
tellement c'est tellement loin la
souffrance que on pourrait penser qu'il
est en droit de ne pas pardonner à un
moment donné on peut le penser on a le
droit de penser moi je le pense pas mais
tu sais quand ils ont réouvert les camps
à Auschwitz il y a il y avait une dame
qui était enfant à ce moment-là qui a
échappé au camp à toute sa famille est
morte etc elle était venue et elle a
reconnu dans la foule
l'un de ces bourreaux qui était là un
des gardiens
et ce qu'a fait cette femme il a reconnu
elle est allée vers lui elle l'a pris
par la main et elle est entrée
dans le four dans le dans la chambre à
gaz avec
ce geste là pour moi c'est ce qui me
donne envie de croire en l'être humain
en l'humanité et je pense que ces vers
ça qu'il faut aller vers la
réconciliation vers la paix et pas vers
la pérennité de la haine il y a des gens
dans cette société qui ont besoin de la
haine c'est ces gens-là qui en veulent à
Dieudonné de demander par une amie aussi
longtemps avant de demander mais parce
que il a pas trouvé ce que j'ai trouvé
pour lui moi j'ai trouvé combien de
temps mais ça fait très longtemps qu'il
a envie de le faire je peux pas te le
dire exact mais depuis très longtemps et
il se heurte à chaque fois un refus de
l'écouter et moi je lui ai présenté
André Darmon et il s'était il faut voir
ce qui s'était mis dans la gueule André
Darmon il en avait dit sur Dieudonné
Dieudonné sur André Darmon et ben il se
sent enfin rencontrés c'est c'est de la
et André il a pris des des risques
énormes pour fournir à Dieudonné le
moyen de demander pardon et ça c'est la
belle histoire de l'humanité tu
comprends quand par exemple lui et moi
on s'est tellement détesté mais vraiment
à un point inimaginable et aujourd'hui
on est les meilleurs amis du malheur
elle est pas belle la vie justement donc
tu vas faire tu aurais signé c'est
possible tu aurais été possible vous
allez faire un spectacle ensemble tu
aurais déjà signé une date avec
Dieudonné au cirque hiver le 7 avril
2023 le spectacle le spectacle va
s'appeler la cage au fou la cage au four
il y aura quoi dans ce spectacle
ben c'est en fait
voilà la fiche je voudrais dire quelque
chose si si ce spectacle a lieu c'est
parce qu'il y a un artiste
qui a fait quelque chose d'essentiel la
première personne qui s'est affichée
qui a affiché son nom à côté de celui de
Dieu donné dans la perspective d'un
spectacle c'est pas moi c'est mon ami
Jean-Marie voilà et Jean-Marie a été la
première pierre c'était la première
personne qui a laissé filtrer l'idée que
ça pouvait être possible après est-ce
que c'est après moi je pense que c'est
une bonne idée moi je pense que c'est
une bonne idée c'est pas une bonne idée
aussi ben ça peut certains peuvent le
penser moi je pense que c'est une bonne
idée parce que il y a quand même une
chose qu'il faut recommencer à dire sur
Dieudonné si tu permets c'est que c'est
quand même un immense artiste un immense
comique on va pas faire l'éloge de
Dieudonné là parce que moi je vais le
faire si tu me permets ou alors invite
quelqu'un qui veut moi si tu m'invites
là aujourd'hui je vais je ne vais pas te
dire de mal de Dieudonné
dans le spectacle je vais je vais dire
aux gens si tu veux savoir ce qu'il y a
dans le spectacle venez le voir mais je
vais te dire surtout quelque chose qui
me semble fondamental c'est que là je
m'engage sur scène sur le côté de
quelqu'un que je considère et que
beaucoup de gens en France considèrent
comme un des plus grands comiques
français un immense artiste et que c'est
ma fierté d'être sur scène avec un grand
artiste c'est pas ça qui revient quand
tu parles de Dieudonné maintenant c'est
pas c'est pas ça qui revient chez dans
ton cercle à toi non c'est ça qui
revient dans mon cercle à moi
voilà alors très sincèrement moi je
trouve premièrement qu'il a quand même
beaucoup de courage Francis parce que on
va arrêter de se mentir citer le nom de
Dieudonné c'est comme Voldemort en fait
dans dans je me rappelle plus de Harry
Potter exactement il a beaucoup de
courage et c'est normal on peut pas
citer son nom et c'est compliqué de
citer son nom par rapport à tout ce
qu'il a pu faire maintenant choqué tout
ce qu'il a fait ah mais bien sûr alors
moi je vais pas mentir je m'en rappelle
personne j'ai vu un spectacle à lui il y
a 3 ans
90% du spectacle impeccable et puis
justement où il arrive où il dérive ou
sur le ton de l'humour il arrive à dire
que c'est qu'on le concentration n'ont
jamais existé moi mon arrière-grand-mère
elle s'appelle kotovic elle a été
déportée je peux vous jurer que c'est
des choses qui me choque et je peux
comprendre tous les gens qui ont été
choqués à travers toutes ces paroles qui
a pu avoir pendant toutes ces années
maintenant la démarche de Francis
demandée pardon déjà c'est bien comme le
disait Francis a peut-être des gens qui
le pardonneront pas et c'est leur droit
exactement mais si ça peut permettre de
ne plus jamais entendre ce genre de
phrase et ça et bien tant mieux moi je
dis tant mieux parce qu'il faut savoir
il faut que ça s'arrête aujourd'hui
malheureusement il y a des gens qui
vivent de ça on vit dans une société où
les gens vivent de la polémique on le
voit bien à travers les réseaux sociaux
ou à travers la télé et ça embête
certaines personnes d'ailleurs que ça
puisse s'arrêter parce que leur fonds de
commerce va tomber on va pas se mentir
il y a des gens qui vivent de ce fonds
de commerce et bien moi si toutes ces
paroles peuvent s'arrêter et qu'on peut
retrouver un dieu donné avec des
spectacles que tout le monde aimera et
certainement pas des paroles qui peuvent
choquer toute cette communauté qui fasse
plus d'horreur en fait exactement et
d'ailleurs si je peux me permettre de
dire un mot moi j'ai pas j'ai je
m'arrête pas là avec Dieudo c'est à dire
que on va partir avec 10 copains juifs
religieux pour faire un mignonne on va
partir à auschwiller c'est une prière
oui d'accord oui je sais d'accord
oui mais il faut dire aux gens que que
pour que ça puisse exister il faut être
10 et donc on va partir moi qui suis
chrétien Dieudo qui est chrétien et 10
copains juifs pour faire le mignonne on
va aller à Auschwitz je vais lui mettre
une qui passe sur la tête et on va dire
la prière des morts ensemble schéma
Israël a de chênes et noix de chez Merad
Barour
il va dire la prière des morts il va se
recueillir parce qu'il a lui-même avec
le recul il s'en veut d'avoir ri et il
s'en veut d'avoir nié et ça c'est
sincère et franchement il a pas besoin
de tout ça là c'est pas un peu extrême
là non franchement non ça fait beaucoup
c'est bah écoute je suis désolé mais
il a pas demandé aussi de faire des
prières là il va le faire oui mais c'est
pas un peu trop non c'est s'appelle une
teuva tu vois je peux dire un mot
là-dessus c'est très important il a
demandé pardon comme un chrétien parce
qu'il est chrétien d'accord et à un
moment donné on lui disait oui mais
c'est pas assez c'est pas assez il me
dit Francis qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
pour qu'ils comprennent qu'ils croient
vraiment à mon pardon je lui dis là tu
as demandé pardon comme un chrétien
peut-être un effort et demande pardon
comme un juif c'est à dire la teuva il
faut comprendre ce que c'est c'est quand
tu as pris le mauvais chemin tu reviens
en arrière et tu reprends le bon chemin
là reprends le bon chemin tu as fait du
mal avec ta bouche tu dois réparer avec
ta bouche tu as fait du mal avec tes
actes et tu dois réparer avec tes actes
c'est comme ça que ferait un juif fais
comme un juif il m'a dit ok Francis je
te suis je vais faire comme un juif
juste Myriam parce qu'après les autres
moi juste je voudrais savoir c'est
est-ce que est-ce qu'il fait pas parce
que moi j'ai tu sais très bien que je
t'aime beaucoup et que je sais que tu es
quelqu'un de profondément humain mais
j'avoue que j'ai quand même beaucoup de
mal avec Dieu voilà j'ai peur que tu te
fasses en bruit c'est vrai mais je sais
pas je le connais pas moi Dieudonné donc
je sais pas dans quelle mesure il est il
est sincère et je sais que toi tu es
très sincère mais pour le coup est-ce
que c'est pas parce que sa carrière
et donne qu'il a fait ça parce que moi
en tant que voilà de confession de
confessions c'est vrai que j'ai un peu
du mal avec tout ce qu'il a dit alors je
lui accorderai
mais c'est c'est normal c'est logique
que sur le procès d'int en disant que
Dieu donnait ça va pas pour lui etc
Dieudonné il va très bien financièrement
il va très bien c'est ça le sont pleines
il a mis en place un système économique
où il a pas besoin d'aider pas besoin
des radios il dit je vais être dans
telle ville tous les gens achètent les
places et à 1h avant il dit dans quel
théâtre c'est plein à craquer il a pas
besoin de tout ça et en plus il arrête
sa carrière et moi attends il a besoin
d'être habilité Francis
ça c'est toi qui le dis ça s'appelle un
procès d'intention alors Jacques Lacan
si ça s'appelle un moment je comprends
que tu sois pour le pardon on va à un
moment ne te fais pas aussi embrouiller
attends attends
merci de te faire du souci pour moi mais
si tu parles ainsi c'est pas ce que tu
connais pas moi je voudrais dire
simplement voilà donc je vais dire
simplement à Cyril qui manifestement ne
le connaît pas non plus
je sais que toi tu es voilà
et simplement te dire un mot te dire un
mot Cyril parce que tu lui fais un
procès d'intention mais tu as le droit
de le faire mais je te recommande la
lecture de Jacques Lacan Jacques Lacan
Jacques Lacan qui dit dans écrit 2 que
en fait on peut pas dissocier l'énoncé
de la personne qui dénonce quand tu fais
un procès d'intention à quelqu'un
[Musique]
pourra jouer très sincère moi ce que je
veux savoir c'est qu'est-ce qui vous a
fait dire qu'on vous l'avez vu quand
vous avez parlé avec lui qu'il était
vraiment sincère et que peut-être on l'a
déjà posé la question sans faute
si tu veux c'est le problème de pas
connaître les gens et de parler d'eux à
travers ce qu'on dit d'eux à la télé ou
dans les journaux et quand on les on les
instrumentalise parce que Dieudo il a
été instrumentalisé et il a un moment
donné il en a il en a joué aussi parce
que c'était sa survie et là et
aujourd'hui le regrette il le regrette
et il en est malheureux et c'est
aujourd'hui de balayer quand quelqu'un
quand quelqu'un a une condamnation lui
il a été condamné pour pour les choses
qu'il a fait mal faite bon à un moment
donné quand quelqu'un sort de prison tu
tu vas quand même pas continuer à le
traiter comme s'il était en prison tu
vois il y a des pédophiles qui sortent
de au bout de quatre ans
qui reste beaucoup non non mais
excuse-moi il y en a qui sortent et on
leur dit ah non non ils ont pu purger
leur peine et cetera il y a quelque
temps une seconde Dieudonné il a purgé
sa peine d'accord attends il en a purgé
deux celle qu'on auquel on l'a condamné
en justice et la peine qu'il a eu de
faire du mal aux gens et pour te
répondre parce que je dois te répondre
ce qui m'a convaincu en le fréquentant
et en le rencontrant c'est qu'il avait
une peine profonde d'avoir fait de la
peine parce que lui ce qu'il veut faire
dans la dans la vie c'est faire rire les
gens il a pas fait rire et ça ça lui a
fait du mal profondément et faire de la
peine ça lui a fait du processus
je voulais dire deux réactions est-ce
que Francis Lalan peut entendre que la
communauté juive ne veut pas que
Dieudonné ça donne à une prière juive
après tout le mal qu'il a fait et il y a
un autre
pour revenir dans la lumière et
prendre du pognon ils sont prêts à tout
la lane est Dieudonné même de devenir
juif si on te question avec moi ça rien
je répondrai alors ça la la haine
gratuite les procédés d'intention et les
les ordures qu'on balance sur les gens
ça m'intéresse pas je réponds à des à
des questions à des arguments voilà je
prends des exclus dans le spectacle il y
aura des excuses mais d'abord c'est pas
des études
en public le thème du spectacle c'est le
thème d'ailleurs qui a été initié par
Jean-Marie avec Dieudonné c'est le
pardon d'accord tout le spectacle tourne
autour du parc et bien évidemment dans
ce spectacle il va il va dire vous allez
comprendre quelle est cette personne et
pourquoi il a eu beaucoup de gens
merci Francis